Le jeune français est très présent sur le territoire national,
et représente plus de 30% de sa population humaine.
Il se différencie du reste de son espèce,
par son incapacité à trouver du travail,
intrinsèquement liée à son inaptitude à sortir de son canapé,
son habitat naturel.
Salut Pascal !
Ah, salut McFly !
Vraiment merci de poser ta voix sur notre documentaire, ça fait très...
Plaisir...
En fait j'improvisais juste un petit texte d'introduction sur le documentaire, voilà.
Ok d'accord, rassure-moi tu as bien reçu mon mail ?
Ouais bien sur avec toutes les thématiques qu'il y aura dans le docu, oui oui.
Ben justement j'ai pris des notes pour écrire ma voix.
En fait nous on essai d'apporter un regard nouveaux sur la jeunesse
de casser un peu les clichés qu'on a l'habitude d'entendre.
Je te propose,
on s'en tient à notre texte,
Ok.
Le tien je le garde  et je le met à la poubelle.
Pardon ?
On a tous entre vingt et trente ans.
Et on a déjà été confronté aux mêmes stéréotypes sur la jeunesse.
Chômage, délinquance, fainéantise, on croirait presque que tout était mieux avant.
Seulement voilà, aujourd'hui en France des milliers de gens de notre âge s'activent à leur échelle
pour construire la société de demain.
Qu'il s'agisse de l'environnement, de la politique ou de la culture,
ces jeunes s'engagent pour faire bouger les choses et eux, on en parle jamais.
Aujourd'hui notre but n'est pas de faire comme s'il n'y avait aucun problème,
mais c'est montrer que des solutions existent déjà, et on vous emmène à leur rencontre.
Donc rendez-vous le 2 mai à 20h55 sur France 4,
On voulait faire un état de la jeunesse différent de ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir.
On espère que ça vous plaira, et rassurez vous il y a aussi des blagues dans le documentaire.